boy that tales of the Citadel episode
sure had a lot of Easter eggs in it huh
return of evil Morty and all that lots
of theory fodder in there am i right
don't worry I'll get to that one soon
enough but there was one detail that I
wanted to point out that isn't enough
for a full episode and one that all the
next day analyses overlook that I wanted
to talk about specifically this chart
see how reverse Rick outrage is at the
end of the chart but still has a 15
percent approval rating which is higher
than the rent is too damn high Rick well
it's an incredibly smart jab at one of
the most subtle ways news media can and
does bias what it's showing you looking
at the graphic most people would think
that reverse Rick outrages and dead last
but he's not and that's even if they see
him at all
they buried him in the back it's an easy
way to discredit a candidate a technique
that was famously used during the 2012
presidential election to undermine the
strong poll results and growing
popularity of Republican candidate Ron
Paul long story short the reason I'm
pointing this out is to not only draw
attention to an underappreciated Rick
and Morty Easter egg but also to tell
you just be aware sometimes the data
doesn't lie but the way it's presented
does
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show where we take your favorite
series let them marinate in our salty
mind brines and pop out crunchy
delicious theories just a short time
later and with that as the opening
sentence of this episode two things
should be made immediately clear number
one we're talking about pickle Rick
today I'm pickle reg and number two
I've got pickle puns for days picking
him up wasn't even that cumbersome or
should I say cucumber some dope I really
really shouldn't sure season 3 of Rick
and Morty may have taken a little bit
longer than expected to arrive but
honestly this was nothing compared to
the way we've got coming for season
eight and Game of Thrones winter is
coming now it's here now we just gotta
wait like two more years when it comes
to Rick and Morty the wait was totally
worth it season three has delivered on
both the lower side and the science side
now in the past I focused mainly on the
lore bits click the link in the corner
of the screen if you're behind on those
but I've never actually spent any time
getting into the Nitty Gritty of what
makes a Rick and Morty not only the
funniest show on TV but also the
smartest parallel universes reality
simulations memory altering parasites
the list of things to explore as as
endless as the channels on an
intergalactic cable box but as someone
who appreciates memes as much as science
no analysis of season three would be
complete without a look into the science
of pickle Rick exactly whether Rick
could realistically turn himself into a
pickle he can't but instead how possible
Rick's alien-esque cockroach and rat
mech suits would be a quick recap in
case you missed this episode Rick turns
himself into a pickle to escape family
therapy I turned myself into a pickle
morty as a pickle he gets washed down
into the sewer drain where he's
surrounded by cockroaches he bites the
head off of one and then manipulates its
brain with his tongue to make it walk
the next we see him he's fashioned a
suit of cockroach armor to kill rats he
dismembers one fuses its limbs to his
pickle body connects his brain to the
rats and then goes on a good old John
wick style pickle murder rampage you
know a classic Rick adventure or should
I say a Vlasic Rick adventure no you
really shouldn't say that cynical
hypothetical viewer you're sounding a
bit older and more grizzled than usual
yeah 30 years of vodka will do that to
you I'm Dan Harmon I'm the co-creator of
Rick and Morty hope
Wow welcome to the show wait did you
just come on the show to tell me to stop
making puns well not just to tell you to
stop making puns I just wanted to save
you the trouble of making this episode
pickle brick is something we just made
up we thought hey what's a funny
vegetable we can turn Rick into and we
landed on a pickle uh sorry but you're
wrong what do you mean pickles are
hilarious no obviously a pickle is
hilarious what I mean to say is and I
hate to correct you but it's not
technically a veggie a pickle is a fruit
because they have seeds pickles are
technically a fruit of the vine it's
decided by the US Supreme Court but it's
made from a cucumber yeah fruit too I
mean if you want to get really specific
cucumber as a pepo which is a type of
berry and a pickle technically fell
under the classification of condiment
but don't worry people will debate it
out in the comments well whatever it is
we just thought making pickle brick
would be funny we do a lot of scientific
research for the show but this wasn't
one of those times
pickle rick is not rooted in actual
science yeah I hate to be the but
actually guy but actually the existence
of this channel tells me that's not true
okay so maybe I really love correcting
my favorite creators just not to their
faces but regardless I wouldn't be too
sure of that one either dan tell you
what stick around for the rest of this
episode and if you're still not
convinced by the end I'll give you a
twenty-five sniffles you know we made
those up too right fine lunch if I don't
convince you I'll buy you lunch hmm well
I have watched all the episodes of
Hoarders on my DVR so I guess I've got
some time on my hands let's do it
awesome we'll investigate this together
just just you and me and then we'll go
on more adventures The Adventures of
Matt pad and Dan Harmon forever and ever
six seasons in a movie maybe let's just
start with the one yeah sorry I just got
a little excited now before we get into
just how plausible these feats are we
should determine exactly what pickle
Rick is is he completely human with just
this pickled exterior is he more pickle
than man Dan can you shed any light onto
this he's a pickle on the streets but a
Rick in the sheets if you get my drift I
really honestly don't look man I don't
know obviously has Rick's brain since he
talks and thanks but it's not like he
has a whole human body inside his pickle
shell when Jaguar shoots him on the side
Rick doesn't bleed but he does feel pain
he also mentions at the end of the
episode that he missed having a stomach
so he's missing a lot of his
bodily system and I miss having hands
and blood and a stomach okay so for the
sake of simplicity let's say that Rick
has a functioning human nervous system
brain spinal cord etc and everything
else that we can see like his eyes and
mouth but that any other body system
that doesn't contribute to his immediate
survival is missing some good deals
let's take a look at the first body that
pickle Rick takes over that of the
cockroach he bites to death after the
roach stops struggling pickle Rick rips
open its exoskeleton and begins prodding
its brain with his tongue after a few
tests he determines how he can activate
the roaches legs and wings thereby
carrying him along with its carcass what
certainly seem at first glance that this
is all nonsense but as with most things
some scientists have already
demonstrated how to do this according to
a study titled central complex control
of movement in the freely walking
cockroach holy crap there's people that
hooked cockroaches up to electricity and
practice mind-control on them for a
salary I am in the wrong profession
seriously I think it'd get boring after
like a day now boring is being
controlled by insects which is the
entertainment industry
wow that was some shockingly honest
spate of shocking and breaking in
awkward silence in that study
researchers proved that by stimulating
certain parts of a cockroach's brain
they could get it to walk change
directions even climb completely at will
Rick's methodology is obviously less
sophisticated but so are the results the
main takeaway here though is that by
supplying small impulses to the Roach's
brain it is scientifically plausible
that Rick could make certain parts of
the cockroach twitch and crawl enough to
carry his briny body along now hold on
just a second there Matt Pat I've read
that study and wait what you have I have
interests beyond fart jokes and Dungeons
& Dragons you know as I was saying that
study indicates that the cockroaches
brain was stimulated with electric
current and probably more importantly
those cockroaches were still alive so
how on earth is Rick getting a dead
cockroach to walk good questions Dan
first thing it is totally possible to
get dead bodies to behave this way by
pumping them full of electricity heck
we've known that dead animals plus
electricity equals movement since
demonstrations in the late 18th century
by a scientist named Giovanni aldini
aldini famously demonstrated that by
hooking a corpses brain to a battery he
could get the muscles in the faces hands
and
eggs to move it was actually this kind
demonstration that inspired Mary Shelley
when she wrote Frankenstein that still
doesn't solve the problem of the
electricity electric pickles while an
excellent band name don't seem very
realistic pickles are actually great
conductors of electricity but you don't
have to believe me check out this
illuminated pickle switchboard created
by Chili's for a rave they were throwing
because apparently Chili's is where
sanity goes to die or bad marketing
decisions get made one of the two I
prefer Shoni hate each their own
at any rate pickles conduct electricity
so well because they're high sodium
content gives them a strong charge and
if we can see that pickle rick has a
normal human nervous system that means
he does have electrical impulses running
through him so him prodding that Roach's
brain with his tongue is the equivalent
of jabbing it with a small battery it
would likely take a bit more trial and
error than we see in the episode but it
would be possible to find the certain
regions of the Roach's brain that
controlled its movement and then
stimulate those to make himself a little
zombie roach wagon you win this round
matpat but then how do you explain
pickle Rick's rat armor there's no
stimulation of the brain there are you
telling me that you think Rick could
control a rat's brain remotely I just
think it Dan I can prove it pickle
Rick's rat suit seems to be controlled
by the rats original brain and spinal
cord which we see him attached himself
to in the episode even linking the rats
brain to his own with a metal spike that
may or may not be a sewing needle with
this kind of brain to brain link it is
absolutely plausible that Rick could
control the rats limbs even if they are
now attached to him in another study
conducted by scientists at the
University of Washington who if we're
being honest for a man just a wee bit
higher than those Roach steering guys
two subjects had their brains linked
through a system of electrodes when the
first person thought about moving his or
her fingers nothing else just thought
about moving his fingers the fingers on
the other person would move now before
he get it into our heads to take over
the classroom bully's brain and get him
to punch himself over and over again
saying why hidden yourself why are you
hitting yourself I should mention that
this kind of technology is in its
earliest stages but let's not forget
Rick is the smartest man in the universe
he can travel interdimensionally so it's
safe to say that he could make this work
his duels are definitely rudimentary but
the mechanism that he uses to
remote-control the rat's limbs totally
makes sense
so humans can control the brains of
other humans yeah but I don't think we
can assume that this means we can just
hook up our brains to anything we want
rats have weak tiny brains pretty much
all they do is scurry and eat and
occasionally teach ninjutsu to mutated
Turtles you bring up a totally
reasonable point but it's not like rick
is trying to get the rat to recite
Shakespeare all that his rat body needs
to do is run jump climb and slash those
are exactly the kinds of things that
Rick should be able to make it do even
though a rat's brain is small the part
of it that controls the rats movement
the motor cortex is actually structured
very similarly to the humans motor
cortex in MIT at Dan the science of
pickle rick is a whole lot sounder than
even you realized cockroach
ventriloquism is just a small electric
charge away and there is scientific
proof that a human brain could control
the movement of a rat's body remotely as
long as their brains are somehow
connected which they are that's all true
but to quote my cardiologist there's a
big problem here and it's salt-pickled
Rick's body is obviously going to be a
lot saltier than that of your average
scientist but as you said yourself
earlier he has a human brain you've got
a degree in neuroscience right pickle
brine blood isn't going to be good for
the brain yeah I was hoping you wouldn't
bring that up fine Dan's right you guys
well it is hard to know exactly how much
of pickle Rick is still Rick the human
parts of pickle rick are gonna have a
whole lot of trouble dealing with the
pickle parts insert your own pickle
parts joke here viewers
I mean you've certainly inserted your
fair share this season Rick's got a lot
to be proud of anyway normal sodium
concentration in the human body is a
pretty narrow range from 135 to 145
millimoles per liter if you go just a
little bit over that to a range of 160
millimoles per liter or higher you start
to experience symptoms of salt poisoning
otherwise known as hypernatremia and if
we imagine that internally Rick's body
fluids are essentially pickle brine
which we kind of see in the episode when
Jaguar shoots him and he starts bleeding
brine everywhere well he's in big
trouble pickle brine contains about 380
milligrams of sodium per fluid ounce so
after we do some conversions to
determine the solutions molarity it's
called math we find that pickle brine
has a sodium concentration of 559
millimoles per liter or about four times
the normal amount found in the human
body which means it's not looking too
good for Rick and it gets even worse
because the highest recorded sodium
concentration in a human was less than
half that amount at 255 millimoles per
liter and that amount of salt ended up
being fatal
the reason salt poisoning is even a
concern is because salt causes cells to
retain water so Rick's hypernatremia
would cause his still human brain cells
to swell with water resulting in
seizures and eventually death so like I
said this theory that Rick can somehow
survive out of his own body is pure
fiction looks like that trip to Shoney's
is all mine well not so fast there Dan
I'll admit that Rick is gonna have a
hard time living as a pickle but there
is a different green piece of Frodo's
that might have worked a little bit
better in avocado avocados actually have
much lower salt content than pickles do
and what sodium they do contain would be
kept in check by their high levels of
potassium which also helps regulate the
flow of fluids into and out of cells
avocados also apparently conduct
electricity because I guess somebody out
there has hooked up a battery to every
food product to see if you can run a
current through it
Plus avocados contain a number of
vitamins that are vital for brain
function and avocados are what the
internet would like to call thick full
of trans fats fats that are essential
for the coating of neurons so signals
can be sent from the brain through the
nerves and in Rick's case to the rats
brain so there you have it damn I mean
granted avocado Rick doesn't have quite
the same ring to it but Rick's plan
isn't entirely without scientific
backing only now instead of fighting
rats he'll have to fight off Millennials
trying to scoop him onto an overpriced
piece of toast but hey that's just a
theory hold on a sec you owe me a lunch
what I just demonstrated that Rick could
somewhat plausibly survive using science
the bet was could pickle Rick be a thing
and not could Rick turn himself into any
item found in a farmers market pay up
hey fine by me going to lunch with the
creator of two of my favorite shows is
not a loss in my book so we going to
show he's then now that was just another
bit
how about Chili's I got a hankering for
some baby back ribs after you mentioned
it it struck me as a sizzler kind of guy
for some reason by the way can we talk
evil Morty just wait until the end of
the season this Sunday at 11:30 p.m. on
Adult Swim or immediately afterward on
YouTube since their live copyright
detection is pretty crap well that's one
thing we can both agree on can we eat
now you drive I don't have a car wait
wait before we go can you tell everyone
to subscribe
shameless plug munch just let your shill
for Adult Swim dude seems even I came on
your show to be poorly photoshopped and
serve as a straw man for your scientific
research you clearly come out on top
here please I'll throw in a skillet
chocolate chip cookie fine subscribe by
doing the bail thing you heard the man
do the bail thing now back to evil more
do you see I've got a decir e coming up